hey what is up guys I'm Kim PhD here and
this is a boosted board an electric
skateboard and this is my friend Sam Sam
knows a lot about Electric skateboards
iWatch shook skateboards can be really
awesome with something like a boosted
board instead of using your feet to kick
and push you use a remote control some
batteries and a pair of electric motors
to go and the advantage is obviously
that it uses a lot less of your energy
meaning you can go further and you can
go faster and if you get really good at
it a lot faster like Sam not like me I'm
not like a pro at this by any means I
mean it's still faster than I would go
on a regular skateboard that's for sure
but yeah you get the idea you can go
really really fast anyway today boosted
the company announced the second
generation boosted board and it looks a
lot like the first one but frequent
riders or big fans of the original will
notice the differences so this is the
boosted board - if you start with the
remote the remote is mostly the same so
it's the pistol grip pretty small and
lightweight and to operate it's the same
way you hold the safety switch on the
front and then you rotate the throttle
along the top to go forwards or
backwards the more you turn the faster
you will go pretty simple the remote
connects to and controls the board via
bluetooth and then also from that is
where it gets the information that it
displays on the side of the remote so
you get the board battery level the
connection status the remote controls
battery level and what mode you're in
and different modes reach different
speeds good to note the differences
between mode one two three and four the
batteries in the remote control and the
boosted board are both rechargeable but
the boosted board 2 now has quick
charging so it will fast charge to 85%
in just 30 minutes and it's now also
user replaceable so in theory you can
carry another battery in your backpack
and a screwdriver to take these screws
off swap it out and effectively double
your range and speaking of range there
is a new range for the boosted board too
and keeps roughly the same weight and
size as you can see about 15 pounds but
now they'll rock either a standard 99
watt battery that'll go six to seven
miles on a charge or we can get the
extended 199 watt battery
that'll boost for 12 to 14 miles so
that's a lot longer than obviously a
normal skateboard ride but a lot more
portable than a bicycle that you might
use to commute that same distance in the
city and there are other smaller
logistical improvements too like the
battery indicator light on the bottom of
the board the first board didn't have
one of these and the two Bluetooth
radios in the boosted board itself so
you can have both your smartphone app
and the remote control connected at the
same time leave it or not the first
boosted board didn't do this either
there is only one Bluetooth radio and
there's also a new accessory port up
front for upcoming modular accessories
that they'll likely sell stuff like
headlamps or LEDs and all the internals
of the boosted board two are now water
sealed in this housing so it's not like
a completely waterproof product but you
can now be that much more comfortable
riding through puddles or riding in the
rain for example and I actually found
the boosted board too easier to ride
than the original boosted board now I
don't know if it's just because I'm more
of a beginner so like I'm still early on
a learning curve to be fair I'm probably
only put in maybe two miles on the
original board but I found the ride
quality of the boosted board to to be a
lot better it has better wheels better
trucks better more efficient motors and
the acceleration curve is smoother it
just overall felt a lot I guess the
keyword is smoother to ride and when I
was writing it I could focus more on
where I wanted to go than on staying
balanced although like I said I'm a
beginner so take that with a grain of
salt overall though no doubt this is a
piece of tech boosted boards and just
all-electric skateboards in general can
be a legitimate mode of transportation
in a stacked place like New York City
like this you guys already know how into
electric cars I am with all their
instant torque and this board has the
same thing it accelerates crazy fast in
mode 4 can go up to 22 miles an hour
that's way faster than I guess an analog
skateboard so if you want a more
in-depth users look at the boosted board
to check out Sam's video he has a
YouTube channel and he's put some miles
in this thing already
and like I said he knows way more about
Electric skateboards so that's your full
review experience and that's pretty much
it I had a lot of fun making this video
and I also now have that much more
respect for people like Casey Neistat
who who managed to ride a boosted board
control it and record video at the same
time that's actually really hard but we
do it for the shot
anyway thanks for watching and I'll talk
to you guys the next one peace